even Carrot Top Got a punch line but
it's visual yeah yeah
oh [__] even a [__] magician goes
Tada
the next thing you're gonna have
magicians with no ta-da I'm like Boo
where's the Tada
a magician
just pull out a rabbit don't say [__]
yeah I'll be like uh-uh my man put the
rabbit back in yeah ta-da I need a tada
I pay money for magic yeah but where
does this like resent because if there's
a there's a feeling and where does it
come from though what what feeling no
what feeling you're talking about no the
emotions that you're going you know why
why
because I don't know who you are
I know you want money but I don't have
any
but I have a particular set of skills
over a long career yeah no listen yeah
what if something something happened no
it's a passion no I'm just talking okay
you always afraid oh my God [__] it you
always do oh he's standing up you always
remember oh
I'm looking at your Bowie shirt I'm like
put that [__] hell headphones that's
a good that's a good t-shirt yeah
we love it yeah so what are you saying
I'm afraid of what listen I'm listening
[Music]
one of my favorite toddlers
okay okay
um what am I afraid of uh no because you
put your fears and reflected on me I'm
like you're like Godfrey calm down I'm
like no I'm just being bad I'm not it's
my passion I feel like I have such a
passion for stand up I love stand up so
much I just like the men and women that
do it well and it's and like I said
there's different kinds and there is a
subjectivity to it it's like Beauty
yeah there's ugly [__] and then
there's Attractive people I want to hear
this book now you can become attractive
because of your personality I'm talking
about visual I'm talking about shallow
[__] there are people who are attractive
you may not be your type like me
like I said
they might not be okay I can't but yes
so
they might not be your type but they're
subjectively there's attractiveness
people go subject no there's ugly and
then there's like good looking people
period it's like comedy there are funny
people and they're just people who stink
but there's of course different styles
of Comedy you might not like to taste
but I'll go no I get why they like this
person they're kind of funny this
person's really funny look I get it but
there's some it's like I don't get it
what are we doing here yeah I mean it is
strange though sometimes I do look at
somebody and go and no one's laughing
and I'm watching I'm going I don't
because usually I can go that's where
the funny is that right even if I'm not
out loudly laughing no no that's the
switch exactly that's the thing exactly
and then sometimes I want someone and
and no one else is laughing but you know
they have some big deal yeah at Netflix
you gotta do this yeah yeah or they oh
this is when you know when you're
bombing in a mainly white crowd
[Laughter]
when you're when you're when your joke
gets reacted with it
yeah yeah yeah yeah see yeah but see
there are this is called racial accuracy
like a black crowd like if it's like it
would be like this [__] out of here oh
bro that's [__] what the [__] man this
dude like or something but when white
car they're so popular
when it's when your [__] is answered
whew
[__] it's I I that's when I used to do
Jay Davis shout out to Jay Davis when I
used to do history memory shows oh yeah
[__] um what is it um
that was when Dan Cook was [__] yeah
dead
when Dane was the man those are fun days
oh my God unreal and
a lot of those shows started becoming
woohoo because it was all celebrities
everybody thought they were Cooling in
the comics and it was like you know
everybody was just like this watching
the show yeah I'd be like oh but Douglas
was great because you if it was hard to
get a spot you had to be killer all
right but once you got upstairs you
would have like two just [__]
business cards yeah you have to go hard
Cameron Diaz is there then you beat
Vince Vaughn's like this that's [__]
great yeah yeah right you're [__]
right you're [__] great it was the
best Tuesday night yeah it was it was
the best you had a good night it was on
even I got [__]
I got [__] now I got the [__] I got
the [__] yeah but it was like what a
great night but but here's the thing too
the [__] game is very weird now it is
socially it's social media made now
because now I'm getting that I'll meet a
girl and she has that I just got a
thousand new followers energy
yeah oh she's like yeah oh she got new
followers yeah she's at Point